yeah so we surfed in Waco so we got like  a million waves this place is amazing  as soon as you said a million waves I  checked out why dude  we went to Waco which also tragedy don't  know if you remember that I was just  waiting a bunch of dead kids beneath  that surf pool did that happen there  yeah they just yeah they just they just  make that [ __ ] over top  attraction and they're like Surf Shop  they built a wave park over top you know  some real estate developer that land  like went [ __ ] minus 30 and he was  like oh easy yeah yeah he's just like  it's cost how much yeah yeah just ran  his cards yeah yeah through the Square  Reader nice little American Express just  swipe yeah yeah